On this episode we start 2016 off
with a bang!
(high-energy hip hop music)
♫ You ask questions
♫ And I answer them
♫ This is
♫ the #AskGaryVee Show
- Everybody this
is Gary Vay-ner-chuk,
and this is episode 173 of the
#AskGaryVee Show.
And I think a lot of you know
exactly what I'm doing right now.
That's right!
I have turned into a 13 year old girl
while I've been away on vacation,
and I am now a Snapchat Queen.
Legit!
I'm excited to be back
everybody. Missed you.
Hope everyone's off to a
tremendous start in 2016.
I had an amazing time with my family,
and have had a very interesting
week at CES in Vegas.
I think a lot of you saw the DailyVee.
You can probably---
Can we like link within ourselves?
Like can I go DailyVee
and then it pops up here
and it's a link to DailyVee 03?
- [DRock] Not anymore on Youtube.
- Why?
- [DRock] There's no link out.
Even within yourself?
That's not true.
Is that true?
- [Staphon] Yeah, now they have cards,
where it comes up on the side.
- So I can do a card with
a still shot, and go to 3?
- [Staphon] Yeah.
- Okay, do that Staphon.
India's here.
Andrew, one of my
favorite all-time interns,
and Vayner employee, now
jamming on his thing, is here.
Show 'em Staphon.
I know the light's in your
way but figure that out.
Andrew, it's good to see you, man.
- All well? Good holiday?
- Yeah, it was good, went
back to Cali, family.
- [Gary] Nice!
And we have a major, major announcement!
Stunwin!
- Hey everybody!
- Who you guys know, especially from--
what are you--
Wow, getting right into it, huh Stunwin?!
I thought, you know what,
by the way you looked a
little like Michael Romo
when I first walked in here.
- Look, I've, I've got...
Facebook tried to tag me as him.
- That's unbelievable!
I saw you just now, it's
like "Is that Romo?"
No, it's Stunwin!
Stunwin, as you can see--
Staphon, this you can do,
can you put a huge sellout alert?
in his full Budweiser gear is shifting,
within the company, onto clearly,
we know what team.
Steve has been a tremendous part
of my team for several years.
We are super excited about
this next step in his career,
and I just want thank you publicly,
officially, for everything you've done.
I love you a lot brother.
- Thank you man.
- And I hope you crush there.
I'm excited that I don't have
to deal with you as often.
I would be telling the
truth in that, I'm kidding.
We're all going to miss him.
India's getting emotional over here.
India, you seem very sad.
- Yes, I am. Oh.
- Did I hurt you?
- Emotions.
- Oh your emotions, got it.
Stunwin, you played the kind of
India role for quite a while.
- [Stunwin] I did!
How many episodes?
Do we know, do we really kinda know--
- [India] I started around, like, 34.
- [Gary] So India, got it.
- [ Steve] Yeah--
- [Steve] I just kinda barely started.
This is her show.
- You know what's so crazy?
This is really crazy, for
everybody who's watching who's
been kind of like, in my
ecosystem for a long time.
Both my video vlog shows
had the same thing happen,
where a signature person got--
Eric Kastner started Wine Library TV
and then, right, I know a lot of you know.
And then Mot, and that
happened to you too.
The first person didn't get as much
love as the second person.
Mott became the biggest sta---
Mott was--when we did t-shirts,
"Link it up Mott" was the
number one selling t-shirt.
And honestly, based on
a lot of the chatter
I see on social media--
like by the way I've been engaging
on instagram and then I
check if they just added me.
And of the last fifteen
people that I checked
who was the last person
they added on Instagram,
four of them--the last
person they added was India.
Now I think it's also because
India's starting to put on
some different kind of content.
I've noticed, India.
So--thank you so much brother.
DRock, good to see you.
Great job the other day.
Filling in all day and then
staying up till 5 in the
morning to get the DailyVee out.
And I'm excited to announce here
that DRock texted me and uh,--9 am?!
I'm sorry to be dissing you.
I don't wanna--listen, I don't wanna
short cut you on any of your hustle.
I hear that you know-- I hear
through the grapevine that you have
ambition for five episodes
of DailyVee next week.
Taking advantage of me in
the rare being here all week.
That is a lot of banter
to start off the show.
Thank you , DRock for,
we're taping late here,
so I assume you're gonna be
here until midnight tonight
banging on this and so
your hustle is real.
Great mood! Excited!
Very excited about a lot of
things going on in sixteen.
And India--
Let's get into the show!!
Yeah!
- [India] Wow!
- Yeah, it's been a while!
Long time!
- [Voiceover] Connor asks,
"Gary How important do you think
"young people are to brands?
"Both in HR and consumers."
- I got into it with Connor
a little bit on social media.
He's awesome though. He's always--
And I understand where he's coming from.
Look I think young people
are massively important.
I think it's been very obvious
if you look at the 4 or 5
social--I would say--
Facebook and Snapchat for sure!
Twitter different.
Twitter was more--it wasn't young.
It never actually was young.
It was very techy.
Tumblr! Tumblr!
Facebook, Tumblr and Snapchat.
Three of what I would
say are the five winners.
The other two being Instagram and Twitter.
Instagram and Twitter--Twitter more
techy, nerdy community than media.
Instagram, more photo,
different kind--like a lot of
different people came together.
But, if you look at the
five social networks
that have popped in the last half decade,
the big billion dollar kind of players,
three of them were built by
the young generation's thing.
I actually --and this is India in my mind,
so I'm glad you're here--
I want to write a piece
around the Facebook and
Snapchat generations cause I
think they're they only two.
That's when different
languages were created. Right?!
languages were created.
I think there's--you
know, I think Instagram
was an iteration
I don't think there was
a Twitter generation.
There's a Facebook generation and
now there's a Snapchat generation.
Guys, there's not a single
kid on campus in America
that isn't ninety
percent, seventy percent,
eighty percent snapchat
with some complimentary
Instagram and then there's nothing else.
So that's what's going on.
I'm excited about young
people's impact on brands.
First I'm kind of ranting about
what him and I were talking about.
The set up for everybody for context
we were more talking about
Snapchat kind of thing.
As far as brands, it depends on the brand.
If you're gonna market and sell to
seventeen to thirty
year olds I think twelve
to twenty year olds are every
important for that brand.
I think people age down to what's cool.
So I think that's where
they become important.
If you're building and selling a brand
I don't think a shampoo targeting moms
should or is impacted
by the young generations
So I think if your product is
positioned to sell eighteen
to thirty, that thirteen
to twenty-two is a bigger
and more important thing
than I think people realize.
That if I was trying to
sell to eighteen to thirty,
I wouldn't start by marketing
to eighteen to thirty,
I would start marketing
probably sixteen to twenty-two.
Thirteen might be a hair young.
So, I think they have a huge impact.
I think they have a huge impact.
I think brands and
definitely social networks
and bands have a lot of
similar DNA that way.
Were you a little rusty there?
- [India] I--no,
- [Gary] Were you thinking?
- [India] I have a cold.
I'm not emotional.
(laughter)
- [Gary] I like how
you're establishing that
you don't give a shit about Steve leaving.
Was that what that was?
- He's not going anywhere
He'll be in the building.
- [Gary] But he's gonna
be on the twelfth floor
and if you know anything
about Vayner right now.
That's like Antacrtica.
India, how many times have you been
on the twelfth floor last year?
- [India] Last year?
- [Gary] Yeah!
- [India] Um, like
definitely less than 10.
(laughter)
- [Gary] Alright.
So, see you Steve!
- [Steve] She's gonna help
me move my desk up though.
- [Gary] Cool. Alright, let's go India.
- [India] From Adbul--
- [Voiceover] Abdul asks,
"Gary, How on earth do you
"measure your progress on snapchat?"
Abdul, that's very easy.
It's called how many views are
you getting on your stories.
A week ago I was getting
three thousand views.
Now I'm getting twenty thousand views.
I'm making progress.
(laughter)
Making progress, Abdul.
We're making progress, Abdul!
Let's go!
- [India] From NIkki--
- Nikki--
- [Voiceover] Nikki asks,
"Gary, How do you tell your
"manager that they overstep boundaries?
"For example 9pm phone
calls and micromanaging.
"Asking for a friend."
(giggles)
- Yeah, a friend.
Nikki, look, I don't know.
I think a lot has to do with you--
One of the great things
that I value in Steve
is Steve and--you know a
lot of the people here.
But Steve, Steve was never ever afraid
to kind of give his point of view.
I think at times just even
scratching his own itch
when the point of view made no sense.
But him and I created
a great cadence where
and this is something I try
to do with everybody, and
the truth is of the six
hundred maybe fifty feel
that comfort zone to be able to say to me
like, hey, you're wrong or I don't agree
or this and that.
It's up to the manager and the
CEO and the leader to create
a comfort zone to create
that kind of conversation.
The truth is if this boss hasn't,
which most don't and I do recognize that,
then you just got to either
roll the dice and hope it goes well
I think you've got--if
you're gonna go to a boss
and you're gonna say, "Hey, you stink."
I do think coming with honey before you
come with vinegar really matters.
I really think the first
taste of a coversation
is quite remarkably important.
I do think first impressions matter.
I think first impression in a micro
level--a conversation--matter.
I often hedge. I think
you've all been
on the receiving end of
this or maybe not everbody.
If I'm delivering bad news
or I want a little tweek,
it's usually gonna start
with "I love you but--
or like "You're really
crushing this; it's coming at
the expense of this--"
I think it's important and
I think you've got to say,
"Look, I have empathy
you're managing a lot
of things or they may not be.
You might be the only person but--
Anything you can do to acknowledge
that you have empathy to their situation.
A lot of times this is the case.
This is a big, big common thing.
Hey manager, Staphon, I know that you have
tough managers above you that are
probably forcing a lot of your
actions but I'm being affected by it.
How do we--this is a problem.
So look--the only thing that solves
conflict is communication.
It just is like, it just is.
And so either you get--and
honestly this is a very
weird thing to say.
I would also in parallel,
if it's killing you,
if you're super unhappy, if
you wake up every morning
dreading going to work,
I would in parallel start creating some
options for yourself whether you're gonna
jump into entreprenuer land,
or work somewhere else--just something.
That if it goes completely
terrible like, the boss
is like "Fuck You" then the
week later you're fired,
that you have some hedge
because I don't wanna give
advice and I'm getting emails in a month
"You got me fired!"
So give that some thought as well.
There is only one answer.
I've given you some context for it.
I could have made it nice and
short--it's communication.
You're just gonna have to
talk to the person about it.
There's just nothing else.
Thanks, India.
- [India] Drew--
Drew. You know what Iike?
I like that I said on Snapchat,
send in your questions and
'm not using any of them.
I like just was completely
disrespective instead--
It was funny--I started
watching them on video
and I just sort of like,
"Oh, crap, I really can't--
I don't have any app right
now to download these--
- Yeah.
(laughter)
- So DRock, I need to find a video down---
like one of those saving
download apps on Snapchat
or like one of the hack
apps so I can start
downloading video questions and
sending them to you guys for shows.
Oh, Drew Bledsoe.
I won this bet.
- You did!
- Yeah!
- I need wine, Drew.
Hey Gary Vee, Drew Bledsoe coming to you
from Whitefish, Montanta.
- [Drew] Got two things
- [Gary] So pretty, huh?!
- [Drew] for you.
- Number one is a little wager.
My Patriots are taking on your
Jets today and I'll bet you a magnum
of double back versus a
bottle of your choosing
that my Patriots, even with just my old
back up quarterback playing,
can take down Ryan
Fitzpatrick and his beard.
Next, question for ya--
Do you think there's a tipping point
for Washington wines, where
the general population
will realize what the wine world knows,
and that is that you can get
better value, better wine,
from Washington than you can from Napa.
Go Patriots! See ya!
- A lot of fun.
Drew, I'll let that play through.
So what now the video can't
even pop up while I'm on?
Or that can happen.
It can't click out. Good!
So Drew, listen, first
of all thank you for
allowing me to win that bet.
I expect to get that wine--
India, can you work with the mail room
to make sure I get that wine.
I'm gonna drink it on this show to give
you one more shout out because I
think you make wonderful wine.
You can go back to two thousand--
when is our show--two
thousand eight, nine, ten--
I've been a long, huge advocate
of Washington statewise.
Stunwin is--got a lot
of ties to that world.
You know what, Drew, I think
much like things in business
and I'm gonna tie this into
a business environment,
Hello, Mike,
I think that, what we tip
Washington State wines,
are the same things that
tipped--let's use it
and do the talk of the now.
It took Ashton Kutcher going on Twitter.
and challening CNN to see
who'd be the first person to
a million followers to
tip twitter mainstream.
I believe what DJ Khaled
did over November December
tipped it because I was affected by it.
I'm like--Oh great, if
he's the biggest meme
and he's doing stuff that's in my genre
and the day that I've been
seeing for the last six months
that Snapchat's aging up--I--
Ooh, this is what it tastes like.
This the mainstream time.
And I go and then I'm
sure everybody's watching
marketing as I've gone,
ten thousand marketers
have gone and it justs--and
they've got groups under them.
And so there's tipping points.
Khaled for Snapchat, to go mainstream,
even though we've been yelling
about it's importance for two years.
But even I, my actions,
have been affected by that.
(India sneezing)
Bless you, India.
Ashton, Twitter, and Washington State
much like the tasting in California,
when the California wines in
'78 beat the French wines,
and it was one writer from Time magazine,
I don't remember exactly
what it was that covered it,
and everybody in American knew.
There'll be a Washington state
wine that comes along that's
twenty bucks, fifteen bucks, eighty bucks.
It'll do something.
President Obama could've
had a Washington State
and everybody raved about it.
- [Steve] He did.
- I know he did.
But not just, Ronald Reagan
put Gundlach Bundschu
a California wine on the
table, but it didin't
become a cultural phenomenon.
Then next president could do it
and for some reason it happens.
More likely, a Kardashian
could fall in love
with a Washington state
wine and that becomes it.
There's just a million things and it--
there's just a million
things and it could come
in many different
directions but it's gonna
take a pop culture moment, Drew,
for it to cross over.
Something that everybody knows about.
Kind of like rosé in the wine world
last 3 or 4 years, it
just started happening.
So it's gonna take something
like that, something
out of left field that you
probably can't think of.
Just like it happens--I don't
think anybody was thinking
that a 15 year DJ in hip
hop was gonna be the person
that kind of started changing
the direction of a platform
that already had a hundred
twenty five million
active, monthly users.
It's not a small thing.
Same thing with Washington State.
They've been making great wines
for twenty years but
it takes a pop culture,
meme, thing to get it going.
- [Voiceover] Angelo asks,
"Gary, I'm 13 and writing a
"non-fiction book. Where
do I start marketing it?"
Wattpad is something
I'm very obsessed with.
A lot of thirteen, twenty
year olds on there reading.
Females.
It depends on what demo
you're going after.
I'm just making--I just
know that Wattpad has a
thirteen to twenty year old
female demo--You're thirteen.
I'm making, probably, stupid assumptions.
You might be writing a book for
fifty year olds-- I don't know.
But Medium--I would start putting
out pieces of content on Medium.
Here's something I would do immediately.
If and when and it seems
like the smoke is there,
Twitter eliminates the
140 character limit,
and goes to ten thousand characters
I, my friend, would write right now
a five to seven thousand--I
don't know how--
character execution of one
of the chapters of your book
and literally the second
you hear that it's real
you--I would have Twitter's
blog on push notification
to your phone.
As soon as it comes,
write that piece, post it,
like control C, control
V because you're ready,
and then, I would take
the link to that tweet
and I would hit and right hook
every single tech writer in the game
and say hey, I just wrote a piece because
maybe your piece will be
the example they use when
they announce to the world that
Twitter has gone to the length.
As a matter of fact,
India, I want an exactly
ten thousand character
piece of content post ready
for that moment.
I want you set-- I want me to set--
everybody to set the
push notification for it
and I'm gonna have it up immediately.
And then I want the coms team to hit up
every single tech book
reporter about my first
post at ten thousand characters.
This was a sh--you know what?!
I was very like--
I was very businesy the last week.
I felt sharp as shit.
What episode is this?
- [India] 173.
- I want a t-shirt one seventy three--
just want it to say one seventy three,
The sharpest!
That's it.
Question of the day.
Are you tired of me
talking about Snapchat yet?
You keep asking questions--
I'll keep answering them!
(bass driven hip hop track)